exceeded expectations most people
eagerly awaited for this season because
of the much awaited season 2 of demon
slayer but if you were to look past the
sequels and such you'll see that we've
got a surprisingly loaded roster now
that the season's almost over i'd like
to give those new shows some shine if
you're one of those people who wait
until the season's over before picking
up a title you can check to see if one
of these shows catches your attention
i'll be ranking these shows according to
what i think are the new shows i had the
most fun with but it's not a strict
ranking by any means our tastes are
obviously gonna differ and this is a
very subjective ranking based on trying
to weigh my enjoyment and actual show
quality so you could end up finding your
gem of the season early on the list
[Music]
however the faraway paladin's not your
typical run-of-the-mill addition to the
genre come on how often do we see an
isakai focusing more on the growth of
the main character being raised by
undead parents to boot by this time i
think you've already got an image of
what the faraway paladin prides itself
on as in isakai it follows a hero's
journey but its strongest appeal comes
in its world building how did the story
come about how is our boy trained and
how does he grow compared to a lot of
isakai that focus on the feats of the
protagonist and wowing us by making him
mow down thousands of enemies in one
fell stroke the faraway paladin takes
things much more slowly and deliberately
make no mistake though our protagonist
mary blood can be quite the badass and
edgy hero and all but the focus of the
story is on character and setting
instead of simply showing off mary
blood's feats and telling the audience
to bask in the glory of our overpowered
issachai protagonist it's an isa guy
that aims to capture the adventure in
exploration and so far i think it does a
damn good job at it
[Music]
and number nine is meruko-chan
[Music]
[Music]
now here's the combination we don't see
too often slice of life and the spooky
horror elements don't seem to mix well
but maruko-chan proves that wrong to be
fair though maruko-chan for the most
part feels like a standard slice of life
but with the creepy still it's not
horrifying and in fact it's quite funny
and even heartwarming at times i know at
this point the show's garnered a
reputation for the fan service but i
don't think that detracts too much from
the show as i said the show's intent on
keeping the audience entertained through
the situation it puts poor mikko through
and that's the mindset you have to keep
in mind here there's not much spite with
how mikko gets scared and is forced to
hold back and the show generally has the
moderately upbeat tone to it if you
ignore the creepy ghosts some that are
drawn with such grotesque detail that
they wouldn't appear lost in an actual
horror anime i recommend this if you're
up for a slice of life with a unique
theme and some surprisingly wholesome
elements
eighth on the list is my senpai is
annoying
i mentioned how meruko-chan is
surprisingly wholesome in some parts and
i think the same can be doubly said for
this next title my senpai is annoying is
a very misleading title because when you
look at it the titular sent by takeda is
probably one of the best bros you can
have yeah sure he teases our protagonist
igarashi a lot he's a very nice and
supportive guy with the heart of
goldberg the title has garnered quite a
bit of a following thanks to its great
blending of romance and comedy as well
as a supporting cast that will keep you
coming back for more but of course the
main draw is the developing romance
between igarashi and takeda and it's
truly a joy seeing how our protagonist
starts coming to terms with their
feelings there are many comparisons to
be made with shows like watakoi and like
watakoi my senpai is annoying is a great
slice of life all around it's got a nice
and vibrant supporting cast to keep you
entertained it's got some very relatable
moments and when it comes to the
relationship between igarashi and dakeda
it's very sweet and funny blue period
comes in at number seven
[Applause]
[Music]
frankly i like these kind of shows every
so often you have these kinds of
dramatic shows that deal with the
struggle of pursuing a craft when i was
starting out with watching seasonal
anime background was one of my favorites
because it just felt so inspiring doubly
so because i'm quite interested in manga
despite being quite the frustrated
artist luckily blue period is here to
bring back that magic but with a
different execution compared to a lot of
shows that deal with the honing of a
craft blue period mostly does away with
focusing on the shonen stakes for me
blue period seems to be more
inward-facing if you get it its main
draw for me isn't the art itself or
educating on the world of manga
publications like bakuman did is more
focused on our protagonist and how he
overcomes his doubts and deals with his
inexplicable focus on art that much is
evident with the more low-key nature of
our hero compared to shonen peers if
you're finding yourself the type of
person with low self-esteem but are
interested in art you should definitely
give this one a shot the protagonist
would be very relatable and it would
inspire you in more grounded ways that
the typical shonen sports anime wouldn't
the show does drop a few places though
due to an uninspired adaptation
especially when it comes to art and
animation which is kind of ironic isn't
it don't you think
world's finest assassin is sixth on the
list
this is a show that was so excited for
coming into the season the season
started i revved up and watched the
first episode and i wasn't disappointed
at all to be honest i didn't expect the
show to even pick up momentum
considering that at first glance it's
not too unique it's an it's a guy with
an overpowered protagonist strong
anti-hero vibes and a harem oh and the
guy behind redo of gila is also
responsible for this one that's not
really the formula for a stellar
reputation now is it the world's finest
assassin overcame the odds and captured
the hearts of many anime fans people
often rave about the opening that
everyone seems to love but moving past
that world's finest assassin manages to
execute its isakai tropes well throwing
in some subversions along the way for
starters our protagonist wasn't some
perverted neat in his previous life so
no mushoku tensei controversies for you
there second it's also got an
unexpectedly intricate world with its
magic systems and it's in here that we
can see the various creative
applications that fans of magic systems
have often wanted our protagonist is
actually competent and doesn't just
brute force his way through everything
and while he does get his mandatory
harem the girls are all appealing and
given luke's history in his previous
life the charisma he exudes to attract
them is justified if you're out for a
power fantasy that's so much better than
what you'd expect then make sure you try
this one out
like battle royale stories like the mind
games and the cerebral aspects that you
can often expect from such titles enjoy
seeing the real world intertwined with
the supernatural world of angels and
spirits platinum end is probably the
title that you're looking for this
season i want to make this clear from
the get-go this is not a second death
note despite coming from the brains that
gave us death note platinum end ends up
being more like the future diary than
anything the duo have done before
platinum end is an edge fest of
magnificent proportions it's quite
predictable with its tropes but that
doesn't mean it's not entertaining i had
a great time watching everything unfold
and the fan service and the outlandish
fights have their charm yes by a lot of
measures platinum end can be seen as a
train wreck but for me to place this
high i'd say that it's because it's a
damn entertaining one at that it won't
blow your minds like death note not be a
trigger of inspiration like barkleman
but i never found myself bored watching
this thing it juggles the brute nature
of battle royale anime with some pseudo
intellectual elements from psychology
and philosophy to create a rather
immersive show that refused to let me go
speaking of wanton destruction tact of
destiny is fourth on the list
visually this is the anime among the
list that quickly stood out in a massive
way well that is to be expected when
you've got an action anime handled by
both madhouse and mapper still from the
get-go tacked up could have faltered
into a mediocre cash grab to serve as a
commercial for an ambitious mixed media
project led by a gacha game with its
gimmick being tied to classical music
but
it's not as a standalone anime tactop
destiny manages to stand on his feet and
to be a joy to watch while it's quick to
focus on the eye-popping animation i'd
also like to appreciate the way its
story was developed admittedly it's not
the most original title out there but
execution is king and thanks to the
banter and the chemistry between the
characters as well as the cool fights i
found myself enjoying this one so much
not to mention it also got me interested
in classical music too actually tagged
up destiny really reminds me of vv and
that show is one of the biggest sleeper
hits of its season possibly of the year
in fact in the end tank top destiny
proved gacha game adaptation doubters
wrong it's not anime of the season by
any means when you look at the hit or
miss nature of gacha game adaptations
this one sits nicely along with the
likes of princess connect re-dive and
fgo babylonia are some of the better
ones
here's a surprise entry now super crooks
i know some of you have been craving for
the western great pretender-esque
aesthetic and the anime gods have gifted
you with super crooks releasing midway
through the season super crooks caught
everyone off guard i certainly didn't
see its impact coming from my pre-season
look but it ended up being one of the
better ones this season had to offer the
first thing that stands out for
supercrooks is the aesthetic it looks
like an anime version of a hollywood
movie giving off that whole western
superhero vibe if you were to ask me
past that i think the super crooks
handles itself rather well by giving us
characters to empathize with there are
film conveniences every now and then but
it hardly detracts from the enjoyment i
had when i was watching it super crooks
is easy to follow it's enjoyable and
could be a gateway for people into the
whole anime thing for those who want
anime but still harbor a strong love for
western stories perhaps super crooks
will be the show to satisfy you as it
treads the boundary of both mediums and
definitely makes it work
[Music]
for our runner-up we have gomi-san
was one of the most anticipated anime as
the season went on let's just say that
it more than lived up to the
expectations and the hype that everyone
had for it among the titles we have now
it's safe to say that gomi san is
probably the most readily recommendable
show out of all of them this is a show
that can be enjoyed by everyone and it's
one of the best ones that you can open
and unwind to after a long day now at
first glance gomi said it seems like a
typical slice of life we've seen a lot
of those but i think that among the sols
we have i think it's the third on our
list in fact gomi san has the most
charming characters they're all really
quirky and memorable in their
interactions and that's something that
the genre has to lean on to make up for
the lack of an overarching plot it's one
of funny moments where these characters
can shine in and the production value is
excellent overall could it be not to
everyone's fancy well probably
especially if you're looking for high
stake plots that make you think about
life however even people outside of its
target market could surely find
something to like in the charming world
and characters of komi-san
so for this season our best new anime is
ranking of kings
now this really did come out of nowhere
ranking of kings is a show that had to
overcome insurmountable odds it was a
late coming to the party debuting midway
through october it also didn't have the
most attractive and eye-catching art for
an anime typically speaking i mean the
thing looks like a children's show even
the premise doesn't even sound that
gripping death and mute child wanting to
be a king goes on a journey with a
shadow friend but boy the show did pick
up and make a believer out of everyone
once the ball got rolling what i
especially love about this anime is the
sheer amount of depth it contains in its
characters and world i know i don't mean
depth as in high sounding science or
philosophical babbling that you often
see in stuff like mahoka what i mean are
the actual depth of the characters and
their sides that the viewers will enjoy
uncovering as you wade through the
thrilling episodes you can really feel
that you're in it with the characters on
their journey and explorations as you
learn more about the world they're in
the show's exciting not because of its
ufo table tier fights but because
there's always something new to be
learnt ranking of kings still has more
than a dozen episodes left in it but if
this goes on i'm pretty sure that this
will be one unforgettable anime if
you're on the fence about giving it a
shot let me tell you do yourself a favor
and watch what i will nominate as anime
of this season
[Music]
how is that for a shocking finish coming
into the season did you see ranking of
kings being one of the best titles i
mean i didn't i'd love to know what you
thought of it when you first saw it be
sure to also check out my other videos
and you might find something you like
memberships will open access to more
video so you might want to consider that
too otherwise helping me on patreon
which is in the description box will
allow me to make even better videos next
time for you i hope you had fun today
because i sure as hell did i hope you
have a great day and i'll see you in the
next one